[Música]
é é nós somos produto de uma série de
interações interações com o ambiente em
30 interações com a nossa carga genética
e e das leituras que a gente faz dos
contatos com quem a gente tem durante a
vida os filmes que a gente vê cada um
influenciado de uma certa forma o nosso
primeiro malvado preferido doutor smith
e eu não poderia ter sido diferente
depois nos anos 70 e 80 é a jornada nas
estrelas
vida longa e próspera terra formadores e
enfim a influência foi vindo até que
chegou ao nosso querido darth vader a
força a mitologia de guerra nas estrelas
que tanto me influencia até hoje no meu
trabalho na minha no meu dia a dia
o exterminador do futuro que não poderia
estar mais atual do que nos atuais
tempos né onde se fala muito e meio
ambiente nós estamos na fase oral se
fala muito mas fala faz pouco sobre o
meio ambiente
matrix onde a gente não sabe o que
realmente é verdade aquilo que a gente
vive que a gente assiste nos jornais
até onde existe a verdade e à leitura
leitura de livros variados como esses e
tantos outros que eu assistiria nas pré
estréias dos cinemas que hoje são só a
lembrança aqueles cinemas de rua de
copacabana
todo esse conjunto de informações foi
criando a mitologia à mitologia que eu
aplico no meu trabalho
desdobramentos dessa mitologia
bom eu queria ser astronauta via comum
no mundo da lua
como bom canceriano e vi que não ia dar
aí falei pra minha mãe quero ser piloto
de helicóptero ele falou minha filho não
é perigoso de forma ilegal não
periculoso não vou pagar u a aula de
helicóptero
aí numa aula de ecologia em 1982
misturado com os mergulhos de angra
escolha biologia minha mãe ficou
felicíssima imaginou o filho dela
resguardado de todo mal
cuidando de plantas passarinhos e nada
iria acontecer de mal bom
e lá fui eu é para os manguezais onde
nesse importante ecossistema eu conheci
uma das verdadeiras faces da força é um
ecossistema fundamental para a
biodiversidade da zona costeira feliz do
pa do país que tem esse ecossistema e
sabe gerencial responsável pela
depuração da água só para vocês terem
uma idéia os manguezais os ecossistemas
são capazes de concentrar cinco vezes
mais carbono em média do que qualquer
outro ecossistema que a gente conheça no
planeta
conheci sua fauna aprendi que os
manguezais eram protegidos por leis
várias leis desde 1965 no brasil
conheci seus moradores
meus parentes outro canceriano e me
preparei sem saber pra próxima grande
batalha a batalha por angra de 1989 a
1991 foi chefe do departamento de
controle ambiental da prefeitura de
angra com 25 26 anos
lá eu encontrei o descaso total órgãos
governamentais que eram pagos para
proteger os manguezais legitimavam a
destruição dos manguezais
eu e meu pequeno grupo o exército de
brancaleone angra
conseguimos paralisar tudo paralisamos
mas com custo muito alto pessoal várias
ameaças de morte
tive de fugir do brasil 1990 todo mundo
lá fora na alemanha na áustria onde
estive tinha dificuldade de entender
porque eu estava fugindo porque no
brasil quem cumpre a lei tem que fugir e
eu tive de fugir senão seria morto
voltei voltei da alemanha e entrar em
outra batalha
entrei na batalha da baía de guanabara
não pior do que aquela que eu tinha
vivenciado na baía de ilha grande
os manguezais sendo degradados pelos
mais variados motivos
a biodiversidade se perdendo mas nesses
últimos 20 anos de atuação na baía de
guanabara
o de recuperar aproximadamente 2 milhões
de metros quadrados demande nas áreas
piores da baía de guanabara no canal do
fundão no aterro de gramacho
só que como bom filho de napolitano
batalha comigo mesmo e aí nós chegamos
aqui na baixada de jacarepaguá né
é o paraíso do sertão carioca de
magalhães correia esta é uma imagem de
1936 onde você encontrava tamanduá você
encontrar uma onça você encontra de tudo
mas já em 1936 magalhães correia
alertava nós temos problemas ambientais
que têm que ser sanados bom
o tempo passou e uma cidade foi
construída foi criada na baixada de
jacarepaguá no sertão carioca
repetimos exaustivamente os mesmos erros
que foram um motivador os elementos
motivadores da degradação da região
metropolitana do rio de janeiro
crescimento urbano desordenado falta de
políticas públicas em relação à
habitação falta de saneamento
universalizado transformado numa máquina
de fazer dinheiro fácil pra estruturas
governamentais
as bacias hidrográficas transformadas em
valões de esgoto na baixada de
jacarepaguá como praticamente em toda a
região metropolitana do rio de janeiro
não há rio
nós temos uma cidade chamada rio de
janeiro que todos os riscos estão
praticamente mortos
isso eu tô falando no século 21 não tô
falando no século 18 século 21 cidade
olímpica e é só procurar o mau cheiro
está por toda parte aliás semana passada
a barra da tijuca sedia o ovo podre
porquê porque as lagoas são um penico
muito raso para a quantidade de esgoto
que é lançado diariamente nessas lagoas
e aí nós temos o quadro da lagoa da
tijuca essa aqui fica aqui atrás onde
praticamente a lagoa foi transformado
num canal raso pútrido cercado por ilhas
de lama e lixo
são 76 milhões de metros cúbicos de lama
e lixo
toda essa porcaria na maré baixa desce e
vai para o principal ativo econômico da
cidade do rio de janeiro ativo econômico
ambiental que são as praias milhares de
metros quadrados de praias são
contaminados
inclusive o campeonato de surf que era
han a efetuada em anos anteriores nessa
região foi transferido para outro
município
por que dois anos atrás uns atletas do
mundo inteiro passaram mal e tiveram
diarréia vômito
uma vergonha para a cidade do rio de
janeiro e as lagoas da rotam a rota o
gás sulfídrico metano
se o governo se as autoridades públicas
são o que são que nós sabemos o que são
a população também não ajuda
jogam tudo dentro dos rios caixa d'água
sofá dá pra montar um apartamento e aí
nós tivemos as olimpíadas da mesma forma
que tivemos os jogos pan americanos
aí são as mascotes cole e forme uma
amarelada por hepatite a outra tá
cianótica
né parece que nossas autoridades não têm
vergonha na cara e realmente não tem
esperamos os legados olímpicos da mesma
forma que esperávamos os legados dos
jogos pan americanos
aconteceu isso nada praticamente
absolutamente nada
pagamos um mico internacional mundial e
ter galáctico as aquelas aquelas esferas
nem aquelas e aqueles arcos olímpicos
estão aí né
nós temos nossas garças nós temos os
nossos peixes mortos
isso tudo protegido por lei que no
brasil não falta nem lei nem órgão pra
não cumprir a lei
as capivaras morre até os animais mais
resistentes não suportam a nossa
incapacidade gerencial
os jacarés que são ativos ambientais que
poderiam ser utilizados para o
ecoturismo então condenados como as
capivaras nessa foto a viverem no lixo
as capivaras no lixo e os jacarés no
esgoto
e não são só a fauna tida como não
evoluída ricos e pobres respiram gás
sulfídrico e metano e parece que
acostumar nos prometeram isso essa água
azul da lagoa de jacarepaguá e até com
golfinho
mas o golfinho encontro é outro é esgoto
é lixo mais um estelionato com as nossas
expectativas bilhões 40 bilhões de reais
utilizados para tudo que é obra e
simplesmente praticamente nada para o
meio ambiente novas batalhas o que fazer
fica assistindo o circo pegar fogo não
fazer absolutamente nada
manifestações e quando as autoridades
brasileiras de série pra vocês que não
tem dinheiro elas mentem
elas vêm têm nem
porque só nessa rua chamada maracanã
estádio que está abandonado ao deus dará
foram gastos 1 bilhão e 600 milhões de
reais em dinheiro mais do que suficiente
para recuperar todo o sistema de lagoas
todas as bacias hidrográficas dessa
região e melhorar a qualidade de vida de
um milhão de pessoas
sabe qual foi a prioridade gastar 1
bilhão e 600 milhões em obras
superfaturadas
queria dar um exemplo já que meu tempo
vai escoando a batalha pela lagoa lagoa
rodrigo de freitas
cheguei na lagoa rodrigo de freitas
no mesmo período em que eu trabalhava na
prefeitura de angra no mangue móvel do
meu pai eu colocava as mudas de mangue
dentro do carro e lá ia eu com o carro
todo final de semana planta mãe que eu
tinha uma namorada que não gostava de
acordar cedo e tão pouco pra então da
planta-mãe aí ea planta mangue eo
pessoal me chamava de maluco
a outra coisa quando chamar vocês de
malu principalmente no brasil tenha
certeza que você está no caminho certo é
perfeito é balé o cara diz música até
você é maluco é de ótimo todo o caminho
certo tô conseguindo o caminho certo bom
comecei a planta mãe na lagoa porque
como biólogo soube através de
levantamento bibliográfico que havia um
mangue na lagoa só que logo em cogill
50% em 100 anos
bom só que eu descobrir outra coisa que
quem cobra pelo serviço de tratamento e
coleta de esgoto utilizava lagoa como
latrina
nos organizamos muitos peixes morreram a
sociedade se organizou abraçou a lagoa e
nós conseguimos junto com o ministério
público estadual exigir que quem cobrava
pelo serviço não fazia de fizesse
incrível para o de morrer peixe e semana
passada tivemos essa matéria num grande
jornal aqui da cidade dizendo que a vida
estava renascendo o que eu quero dizer
com pra vocês é que essa tragédia que
nós vivemos no rio de janeiro seja no
ambiente
seja na saúde seja na educação seja essa
pouca vergonha que nós vivemos é nossa
culpa é nossa culpa
nós é que elegemos essa gente e nós é
que não exigimos dessa gente qualidade
na prestação de serviço a natureza está
esperando é atitude nossa nós temos de
ter vergonha na cara o que ofereço a
vocês como morfeu dessa vez eu lembrei o
nome é você pode tomar uma pílula e
continuo achando que tá tudo lindo
maravilhoso que ano que vem vai ter
carnaval graças ao apoio que vai ser
recebido né
falta dinheiro para tudo mas para o
carnaval não há de faltar ou você toma
uma pílula que no brasil vai te fazer
acordar você vai perceber que você tem
brio amor próprio e o que você exige da
máquina pública e da sociedade é
vergonha nós precisa nós tocamos o fundo
agora é a hora de subir para a frase
ando meu amigo yoda
eu às vezes pedia para alguns alunos
fulano vai fazer isso vou tentar
brasileiro tem mania de falar vou tentar
não quero que tente eu quero que faça eu
tive um aluno que era o anderson o
anderson era militar
ele falava assim moscateli comigo não
tem essa de tentar
eu recebi uma orientação no quartel que
o superior dele dizia da teu jeito
da mesma forma que a gente dá jeito pra
pagar os impostos que o poder público
deu jeito dele para resolver os
problemas porque ninguém pergunta pra
gente a gente tem dinheiro pra pagar
iptu e ipva e imposto de renda ou o raio
que os parta
então eu também não quero saber dos
problemas do governo
eu quero é solução porque eu voto neles
é pra eles me darem solução e eu estou
aqui para colaborar também nas soluções
aqui estou eu com meus clones
reprogramadas trabalhando a favor da
aliança rebelde
eu não tenho dúvida que essa tragédia
que nós vivemos é produto da nossa
apatia
não sei se dá é para os antropólogos
progenitores geneticistas
eu nunca vi povo tão corno manso que nem
o nosso temos de reagir
o tempo urge a natureza exige que a
força esteja com ele
[Música]